you  I have no job no money and my powers are  evaporate I just killed Tony Stark so  now the kids don't want me around  anymore  oh good hey get away from my car dark  jokester what's this doomsday devices  complete the whole world what are we  supposed to do I will take care of this  I'm going after this clown who's coming  with me that's right it's me B Vereen  the fall not really feeling my farts  right this is so ridiculous super what  hilarious  it's time to stop your grinnin or a drop  superb at supersonic idiotic  double-decker ding-dongs just took out  the perimeter port now super bad you may  die  hey you know what hold on one second  sorry about that I can't wait to see you  [Music]  you